now when we're talking about good and
evil I really only have this one little
metric that I judge people by which is
whether or not they are subscribed to
the New World review which grant some
regular huntin content uploaded straight
into the YouTube feeds and if they
aren't what the hell how morally
questionable of them
hello and welcome to the new order video
source for everything anime and manga
and today I would like to take some time
to discuss a particular character who
tends to fascinate me to no end being
hunter hunters Isaac nedra and this is
primarily because he occupies very
strange place within media being a
character who is very difficult to
define in any standard storytelling role
to the point where it's problematic to
even discern the most basic of labels
for this man and in fact against all
stereotypical Shonen logic actually
believes that network could very
potentially be viewed as one of the
grandest antagonists in all of hunter
hunter but firstly it's important to
note that within the greater context of
Hunter hunter toga she goes to great
lengths to cloud his world in a
permanence of gray area figures who
cannot be called simplistic things like
good or evil not for the most part
anyway in addition to that even our
protagonists are also often the subject
of intense question and scrutiny in
regards to their own actions which is
particularly true in the cases of gone
and crop occur who are very potentially
going down that old road of living so
long that they see themselves actually
becoming the villains and this
definitely isn't a blanket condition of
the characters of hunt hunter and there
are a few sources of strictly definable
things such as say knuckle for example
he is a good boy through and through and
on the opposite end of that spectrum we
have someone like gyro who is an
epicenter of the purest form of evil
that we have encountered thus far yes
even more so than a certain prince
however for the most part characters
inhabit this weird middle ground
especially when it comes to hunters
actually and the thing about hunters is
that as much as they are respected and
revered throughout the world in reality
they don't particularly exist to serve
the world like an organization of Heroes
or other role model star figures in fact
hunters seem to exist purely to serve
their own selfish interests given
endless resources contacts and access to
enact whatever it is they wish to do
it's almost like a form of nobility one
that can quite readily be abused without
fear of retribution for the most part in
fact in the hunt bylaws there is no
specific mention about things like
murder of citizens or otherwise average
people but there is an article that does
expressly forbid targeting other hunters
so basically the rules are do whatever
you want just know
against your fellow members of status
and as such your standard hunter is
going to be a generally questionable
personality and they take the time state
all of this because at the very top of
the hunt hierarchy the being who
observes this nobility system in play is
the chairman our focus of today
Isak network as effectively the king of
hunters network goes on to personify
both the most admirable as well as the
most terrifying aspects being a hunter
and I believe that at best you could
characterize him as morally ambiguous
that's something that I don't think is
particularly clear when we first
encounter net row in Hunter hunter
although in retrospect it is most
certainly there however upon initial
examination he would seem to fit the
archetypal mental role a wise old quirky
and in this case pervert a man who has
the purpose of guiding our protagonist
or protagonist plural and teaching them
all sorts of important lessons to put
into practice on their journey but the
truth of the matter is far more sinister
nature oh is an illusion of this role
with his true self concealed beneath
this quirky exterior a shell that would
be shed over the course of the series
but when thinking about this I always
come back to the words Biscay during the
Chimera ant arc where she states that
net Row is notorious of being
unreasonable which by that point is
rather obvious as he will generally push
people far beyond their limits for the
sake of a needlessly convoluted task and
he does this mainly for his own
enjoyment really which becomes clear
when Neto rose driving forces revealed
which is that all his life he was
constantly in search for strong opponent
a simple idea but one that is inherently
selfish and you can see this at play in
all of metros actions he has won
paramount mission within his existence
which is to foster the strong and weed
out the weak in many ways natural his
motivation is quite similar to that if
you soak her because while they
certainly don't derive the same sort of
sensation from facing powerful opponents
everything they do is in service of that
purpose primary difference being that he
soccer is much younger and doesn't have
the entirety of the hunter Association
at his disposal
although consider for a second what you
think would happen if we made Hisoka the
chairman who said Association he would
in all likelihood not take the position
seriously at all and radically abuse his
power in an effort to discover hidden
potential to service his own personal
needs and you know as it turns out
that's effectively what nattara did as
well as leader of the hunter Association
natural oversaw an incredibly brutal and
merciless exam with no thought given
whatsoever to those who would lose their
lives during the course of it because
natural holds
no respect for the weak and the result
of the exam was the production of beings
who one day might be able to provide him
with something of an ultimate opponent
because by this point Natura had
travelled the world even to the dark
continent and he had not managed to find
what he was looking for so he judged it
the only way he may find such thing
would be to mold it for himself so if
you think that he so good grooming gone
is a creepy and deeply immoral aspect of
that character then you should probably
feel the exact same way about Natura
in fact on many levels network could be
characterized as being worse than Hisoka
because at the very least the mad clown
makes his desires known while snatcher r
operates from a much deeper aspect of
himself
essentially masterminding the world to
provide him with what he desires most
and thinking back on it you can really
see how cold-hearted he is in instances
like the match between gon and honza
well the final phase of the hunter exam
in general actually which was
deliberately crafted to be a brutal
affair whereby inflicting pain and
demanding submission was the main goal
rather than allowing the sweet and
instant escape of death and then of
course intently watching gone being
repeatedly physically beaten for three
hours which says to me that once again
I'm very best you could call natural
morally ambiguous in this very moment
but at the very worst you could call him
a sinister architect for crafting these
conditions with this exact goal in mind
now it's count to this idea there is
another example jury monitor exam when
natural offers to give gone and kill
what their licenses on the spot mind you
if they can best him in a ball game and
this is another one of those things that
makes natural look like a mentor at
first as if he is taking the opportunity
to train the two of them but another way
of looking at it is him having fun at
the expense of those that he views below
him as well as surveying and cultivating
potential challenges for his future and
that might sound like an incredibly
harsh way of putting it but I very much
believe it even if by the end of it
Metro and axe what seems like kindness
by having them slow down so that Gong
can rest a bit more I really don't see
this as any different from he sokka's
act of kindness and giving gone his tank
during the fourth phase of the exam he
just as with natural had an innate
desire to see God grow but in addition
to his views on exam candidates naturae
also shows blatant disregard for the
lives of those within the Association
itself which is most profoundly
demonstrated through the installation of
Power Stone Hill as vice-chairman natura
committed this action almost exclusively
to entertain and provide something of an
administrative challenge to himself
budget first sure that seems like a fine
employing someone with a very different
philosophy can be helpful in seeing
situations from unique perspectives
however that was not the case
Barristan was an unbridled force of
chaos who was heavily implied to be
responsible for the deaths of many many
hunters over the course of his tenure as
vice-chairman as well as generally
perverting the structure of power for
his own personal use
all of which network was very well aware
of that he simply did not care that's
because parastone was entertaining and
capable of challenging him on some level
at least and that desire trumped concern
for the lives of his theoretically
valued hunters within the organization
now Turo gist doesn't care and I guess
that also very much plays into his core
belief of power he does not respect
those who do not possess it or fall to a
greater force and that's quite a
terrifying feature in a leader because
it means that he will willingly throw
you into chaos or even simply abandon
everything you know and love based on a
trivial personal desire and in many ways
the world we see at the beginning of
Hunter hunter is a direct result of
Metro's overwhelming influence I think
mean the chairman of the Association for
as long as he has I would actually love
to know what the hunter exam was like
prior to his ascent to power because we
do know that after Cheadle took over as
chairman she drastically reformatted the
exam to focus less on cultivating the
powerful and to take a more cerebral
approach I mean the first phase of the
289 exam was a psychological examination
and the final exam was a simple Q&A
session which held a record amount of
candidates for the final stage of a
hunter exam although to be fair this was
also because cheetah was seeking out
individuals to accompany them to the
Dark Continent so it had a double
purpose this time around
still it shows the extreme amount of
influence that the Chairman has on the
structure of the exam with Cheadle's
being much more forgiving of the week
and I have no doubt that what it means
to be a hunter will continue to change
and evolve under Cheadle's guidance so I
really do think that you can credit
Natura directly for a lot of what we
take as a basic feature of on tanta
which is its brutality and generally
unfair nature and now I suppose that
can't be applied to the entire world but
netter almost certainly had a hand in
sculpting it this way to resemble his
ideal reality where the strong prevail
and the weak disappear a very
antagonistic feature if you ask me and
that's not to say that he didn't
Institute any policies for the good of
humanity I mean for example he was the
one who lobbied 2v5 to enact a travel
ban on the Dark Continent
which was also extended to hunters and
that was obviously for the good of the
world because otherwise we would just
keep bringing
laughter calamity in to threaten and
destroy everything but an argument can
also be made that naturally did this for
a selfish reason as well because we know
his thoughts on the Dark Continent and
it does not appeal to him because there
is no strong opponent to face off
against her and I highly doubt that he
would have wanted that existence to
extend to the realm of humanity because
it would have rendered his own quest
meaningless and on the flip side if
beings like Mara web were readily
available on the Dark Continent and they
don't think that he would have been so
quick to institute such a ban due to his
profound belief in power now speaking of
mr. Mara web net her his battle with the
Chimera and king is more revealing of
his true nature than anything with
Maryland's character arc being one that
invokes an increasing understanding and
value for Humanity as a whole which acts
in stark contrast to net or his complete
disregard for his own species only
valuing a select few although to be fair
they do both share a common respect for
strength however even in that case we
are still directly comparing narrow to
yet another antagonist of the series and
in the end nattara departs this world
leaving a profoundly sinister message
striking pure fear into marijuana for
the first and only time in his life with
these words Mero am king of ants you
have no idea do you you know nothing of
the bottomless malice within the human
heart and at this very moment net Row is
100% the villain of the piece embracing
the most negative aspect of humanity and
turning that into his last-ditch source
of power to exterminate a being that he
despite recognizing as being powerful
and grateful for the challenge and
always viewed as an existence below that
of his own so many people can interpret
this as net ro making the ultimate
sacrifice to salvage humanity however I
very much view it as notorious final act
of self service revealing the depths of
his darkness which to be fair isn't all
that different from humanity as a whole
but still for someone who is being
considered very much the leader of
humanity in the series it makes an awful
lot of sense that Natura would embody
this darkness on an extreme level and
there's just so so much more you can
look at with natural every action that
he has committed in this series is
questionable at the very least and in
many cases has been performed to the
direct detriment of those around him for
the sole goal of personal pursuit Natura
in my mind is a brilliant antagonist one
who has no doubt shaped the world that
our protagonist struggle through day
after day but instead of being
recognized for the
natura has very successfully masked
himself as a beacon of hope which really
does maybe go to show how truly doomed
this world is and no this is not
necessarily the interpretation that
everyone needs to have natural like many
hunt hunt characters is a complex being
that no label could ever come close to
completely defining however as for me I
have no issues whatsoever with calling
Isaak natural one of the finest
antagonists in hunter hunter but what do
you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discourse server if you're keen
for some more hunt onto content and
please do go and check out some my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for regular huntin to glory
delivered straight until YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new old
review and I'll see you next time